Un día sin inmigrantes con ese nombre
decenas de trabajadores de origen latino
manifestaron su descontento en las
calles de Florida decidiendo suspender
sus labores un día para mostrar el valor
de su trabajo para la economía del país
su objetivo principal Mostrar su rechazo
a la nueva ley firmada por el gobernador
ronde santis que exige a los empleadores
utilizar un software especial que
delataría el estatus migratorio de las
personas y les impediría ser contratados
En caso de que sea irregular muy
importante
la acomodamos mucho en 15 16 horas
seguidos sin parar sostenemos mucho
pagamos impuestos también como todos en
Texas otra demostración similar tuvo
como protagonistas a los dreamers son
hijos de inmigrantes en situación
irregular pero fueron traídos a Estados
Unidos desde niños los dreamers son
beneficiarios del programa daca creado
en la época de Obama que ha sido objeto
de una querella iniciada por el estado
Texano lo que podría provocar su
desaparición
por otro lado ciudad de santuario como
Chicago redoblan esfuerzos Para apoyar a
los migrantes el consejo de la ciudad
aprobó un paquete de ayuda por 51
millones de dólares con el objetivo de
mejorar las condiciones de los
solicitantes de asilo Aunque algunas
voces mencionan que no es suficiente
51 millones de dólares durarán unos
pocos tal vez dos meses y eso es solo
servicios eso no es la adquisición de
sitios es una estrategia a largo plazo
la crisis migratoria en Estados Unidos
es objeto de una lucha ideológica entre
republicanos y demócratas una batalla en
la que sólo pierden los migrantes